welcome to the science Asylum I Nick
lucid a [ __ ] and Milton could fit a
six-foot pull in a five-foot shed a pool
no no a pole you went on this all right
how much a dollar
oh you're on wait feet you call yourself
a scientist fine make it a 6 meter pole
in a 5 meter [ __ ] doesn't matter still
works all Mel has to do is move it about
55 percent the speed of light
it's about 369 million miles per hour
fast remember from previous videos that
time passes more slowly the faster you
move you don't notice it because even
your brain is working slower but it's
definitely happening well time isn't the
only thing that's different if the speed
of light is always the same then pretty
much everything else has to change the
closer you get to the speed of light
most of these things change by the same
factor what we call the gamma factor
which in this case needs to be 1.2 mass
is 1.2 times bigger time is 1.2 times
slower and even length is 1.2 times
smaller this happens at a little over
55% the speed of light let's do this
Milton that's ridiculous
why because as far as melon is concern
it's the shed that's moving so wouldn't
he see that shrink yeah sure see
so it's not actually in the shed right
it only looks like it's in the shed nope
it's totally in the shed so you're
saying if I close both doors it would be
completely inside completely well I mean
until the polar the shed explode just to
keep things simple we'll close the back
door in advance then we'll shut the
front door the moment the pole hits the
back door so what did Milton see this -
really understand this we need a
spacetime diagram what axis for the
direction he's moving in one for the
passage of time from our point of view
the pole moves in the shed doesn't so
the pole fits perfectly in the shed from
Milton's point of view the shed moves in
the pole doesn't so when the back of the
shed hits the front of the pole but pole
doesn't fit but look the moment you
close the front door isn't the same
anymore it's a short time later yes it's
only about 11 nanoseconds later but
there's still time assuming the back
door can survive the initial impact and
keeps going it has to make the crown of
the pole move with it but the back of
the pole stays still because it doesn't
know anything about the front of the
pole during those 11 nanoseconds the
shed compresses the pole just enough so
it fits before the door closes that's
crazy
absolutely crazy but totally true what
if I left the doors open and set up a
circuit what kind of circuit let's say
the shed has a power source with the
negative end at one door and the
positive end at the other door the metal
pole has the light bulb that completes
the circuit as it passes through but
only if the pole perfectly fits in the
shed there can't be light for one person
but not the other person right right but
you're assuming circuits turn on
instantly nothing in this universe
happens instantly it might seem to us
like electronics respond to instantly
but faster than you can see is not the
same as instant the fastest the energy
can go from the power source to the
light bulb is the speed of light because
that's the universal speed limit the
circuit must be completed for at least
33 nanoseconds that means the contacts
have to be over five and a half meters
long which is longer than the shed so
the light bulb pole looks more like this
I give up here's your dollar hey pick up
yourself I'm done how would you fit the
hole in the barn let us know in the
comments and until next time remember
it's okay to be a little crazy